as Peri and Friends Armageddon we
learned that 20 of Congress Members Own
stocks in the industries they're
supposed to be regulating how can we
trust them on the precipice of a crisis
hello there you 5.9 million Awakening
wonders thank you for joining me on this
Voyage towards truth the truth that we
must cultivate because those in power
are leading us towards corruption and
destruction
to Russell Brand yeah we've got to talk
to him he's a famous actor right he's
very famous yes what's he famous for
though exactly Forgetting Sarah Marshall
he was in that movie which is hilarious
he's just so freaking good let's get
into today's story now this is an
unusual time for the world who in
threatens Armageddon this is a time
where you want to be able to rely on
your leaders this is a time when you
want to know that Congress is populated
with people with one thing on their mind
the preservation of civilization whether
you're on the left or the right the
preservation of the American way this is
a time for a hero a politician you can
rely on someone who means what they say
and says what they means someone who
represents a new beautiful America of
Integrity someone like Obama who was the
very politician that promised that yeah
he's funny
spider trading would be a thing of the
past don't take my word for it though
here he is saying it lately I've been
talking a lot about the the choices
facing this country straight away it's
nice to be reminded it's from 20 it's
from like yesterday Barack Obama
doubtless has a degree of charm
assuredness absolutely Charisma you can
see
Barack Obama I remember why I was drawn
to Barack Obama this is a president that
represents New Hope New change those
were the buzzwords if not the policies
here he is talking about something that
we care about deeply on this channel
ensuring that politicians have one thing
and one thing only on their mind the
well-being of the people they represent
that they're not distracted by corporate
interest isn't that the number one
challenge they're gonna face the Titan
of corporatism forever in their ear
they're going to need to Stout moral
souls to resist temptation they
certainly shouldn't own stocks and
shares in the companies they're supposed
to regulate 20 of people in Congress
currently do own stocks do you think let
me know in the comments no yeah this is
how Nancy Pelosi uh her husband is has
something like 80 or 90 million dollars
because he just happens to conveniently
purchase or sell stocks right before a
legislation oh yeah she's passing it and
uh so she's just one example and it's
not fair just to pick on her because
she's a Democrat that ours do it too
they literally purchase and sell and
then legislate in order to make money
crazy so all of this uh new legislation
and the inflation reduction act where um
they're putting in billions of dollars
into generating uh parts for electric
vehicles like batteries and chips and
they're they're pretty oh yeah there's
money into the chip they bought like
microchip stocks right before yeah they
got bought these like the invested
millions and millions of dollars into
these microchip companies the very
companies that are getting the listed as
getting the the government contracts
when I was doing research about 11 9
yesterday I saw the day before it
happened on 10-9 the short rate you know
what shorting is in the market yes when
you're you're making money off of it
going down the average short was like
250 Times Higher for United and American
the two airlines that were involved yeah
explain it explain it for the the less
financially just simply you're making
money by the stock going down so 250
times more than the normal day people
bought the day before wow wow it's wild
at all yeah huh [ __ ] is crazy comments
below do you think that that biases the
way they regulate those companies the
fact that they're personally literally
financially invested in those companies
let me know in the comments below let me
know here Barack Obama introduced
regulation to prevent that happening the
idea that everybody plays by the same
rules is one of our most cherished yes
Americans values it goes hand in hand
with our fundamental belief that hard
work should pay off Jordan actually does
look give it he's actually deteriorating
he like very sort of more together and
he's on that a lot less pressure there
he looks like he would be able to get
off that stage if you went leave the
stage now joke he's conservative
I just hear him saying things that are
just Street facts oh look at you no no
you're okay are you okay are you okay
Biden it's the notion that the powerful
shouldn't get to create one set of rules
for themselves and another set of rules
for everybody else
talking about the passing of the stop
act which is stop trading on
Congressional knowledge act in 2013
Obama quietly signed legislation that
rolled back a provision of the stock act
that required high-ranking federal
employees to disclose their financial
information online the emailed
announcement was one sentence long there
was no Fanfare when the Senate and then
the house pass the bill in largely empty
chambers using a fast track procedure
known as unanimous consent that's how
power works and if we expect that to
apply to our biggest corporations and to
our most successful citizens it
certainly should apply to our elected
officials especially at a time when
there's a deficit of trust between this
city and the rest of the country well
that's why in my state of the union I
ask members of the house and the Senate
to send me a bill that bans insider
trading by members of Congress and I
said that I would sign it right away
well today I believe the nose Joe well
today I am happy to say that legislators
from both parties have come together to
do just that the stock act makes it
clear that if members of Congress use
non-non non-public information to gain
an unfair advantage in in the market
than they are breaking the law so just
copy Pelosi's trades at the end of the
day you know they know something just
copy them if it's public it is public
there's people that post on Tick Tock
like their exact trades there's all
accounts that just right in real time
yeah it's not funny yeah so I guess
before it wasn't like they could have
had it private it's crazy very
interesting we were sent here to serve
the American people and look out for
their interests yep that's the basics I
mean this is what politics should look
like but the ceremony should have a
relationship with reality ceremony
should be the performance of a set of
values that are real rather the
instantiation of an invisible idea we
can't sort of show you fairness justice
but here's a ceremony we're gonna sign a
bit of paper we're going to tell you
what it is and then we're going to do it
but of course it was repealed the same
Act was quietly repealed in 2013. so
when they're bringing it in it's all
cancan legs kicking like splashing
fairness Justice when they repeal it
nothing to see it out the front look at
me round the back where'd she go that's
the nature of American politics it's a
performer and it remains a performance
to this day that is why in spite of this
act being passed in 2012 and repealed in
2013 you have 20 of current Congress
members owning stocks and shares in the
companies they're supposed to be
regulating at a time that we've just
come out of that pandemic we've got a
weird president who looks tired and
confused all the time and don't know
where the exit is and during this time
it's acceptable for people in Congress
that own stocks and shares in companies
they regulate how can you oppose the
might of Putin if the might of Putin is
what we oppose how can you oppose
corporatism at all how can you represent
ordinary American people the very things
that are declared in that speech how can
that happen with these kind of stymiean
inefficiencies
because it's all a scam at the end of
the day I don't know what the repeal of
that law that he's talking about I don't
of course I don't know about it I didn't
hear it when it happened
um and I don't know how it happened I'd
be curious because we've been talking
about how they take these bills and they
they're they plug in all these little
things that they want they just load it
all up with fat and and you know that's
where like last year there was a big
hoopla over you know millions of dollars
that were in some big bill for Pakistani
gender studies you know like just
[ __ ] money or but some of them are
Sinister and very pervasive and things
like this it could have just been packed
into a big long Bill and all of them
were just going to be like oh yeah let's
get that one on both sides because they
all benefit How could a public servant
have tens or hundreds of millions of
dollars it doesn't make it it makes no
sense other than they're cheating the
system and they're making their writing
laws to keep themselves completely uh
you know above all the rest of the laws
so I was saying yesterday that we need
to have every single thing separated out
not these big bills with 20 different
completely unrelated topics and laws in
them every single thing separate and
then we'll be able to look and see what
the hell because you and I don't have
time to read a 10 000 page document the
average American
true so they're just sticking it to us
every way they can and trying to keep us
in the dark and look at this a guy like
this is coming out and people all over
the world are coming out and showing the
truth if for people who are willing to
see it is the difference between the
performance of politics and the reality
of Politics the fact that the things
they say in public are the sort of
things that should be happening kind of
tells you but they know what they should
be doing they know what they should be
doing we were sent here to serve the
American people of course they know for
their interests not to look out for our
own interests what I'm My Own inter oh
[ __ ] I hope he doesn't know about Hunter
we should make sure people
paying contribution to Congress is this
right about the time
like just with hooker's Galore spending
his hundreds of millions of dollars that
he that he you know illegally that he
traded for access to his father and did
you ever see the interview with Hunter
where he was actually he admits all this
he's an absolute dirt bag and he was
admitting that he was one time sniffing
um parmesan cheese off of a rug in a
hotel because he thought it was crack
and he was at a crack but he saw it on
the floor and he said
yeah with like you and the hook are like
fighting over the last the last parmesan
cheese off the off the hotel Rod it was
Asiago presidents
son that's something who he adores and
says the President says he's this that
Hunter is the smartest person he knows
it's interesting which actually if you
look at Biden's cabinet it might be true
that Haydn is that Hunter is the
smartest person Biden knows this
spending pays off in major ways for deep
pocketed interests between the 55
corporations that paid zero dollars in
federal income taxes in 2020 for
instance the group spent a combined
nearly 450 million dollars in lobbying
and campaign contributions since 2015
which translated into 12 billion dollars
in tax savings and rebates for the
companies in 2020. I think we're
beginning to see the mechanics of how
politics truly works I think we're
beginning to see what would actually
happen if money was taken out of
politics it would fall apart you
wouldn't have politics it would be
unrecognizable
like you think so many people are so
brainwashed into thinking that these
political figures are here to save
people and to bring good when it really
is just all about money and power at the
end of the day so then when when they
tell you like to put your mask on for
safety Global warming's coming to hurt
you how are you going to trust these
people they have an agenda with
everything that they're doing so you're
just gonna blindly now trust them that
oh well this time it's it's for my good
and for my safety yeah how are people
this ignorant I don't understand so when
people start out in politics they
usually are still ideal idealistic and
they're going to come in and they're
going to make a change and make life
better for you know they'll start on the
local level their community and rise up
through the ranks so but the second they
get in there with their all their ideals
and their bright shiny you know tail and
their tails wagon bright shiny eyes they
get a really rude awakening of how
things are and how vicious it is and
that they're all just in it for the
money and they're you've got corruption
at every single level the school board
in a small town up until the president
of the United States and Beyond so it's
just it's really disturbing and I think
that people many politicians do start
out idealistic they just get seduced so
quickly by the crime interesting and if
Britain without the monarchy is no not
Britain anymore that's what defines
Britain you take dirty money out of
politics in your country in our country
probably in most places around the world
you wouldn't have a recognizable
landscape you won't get the same people
in it you won't get the same laws passed
you won't get the same it will change
the world overnight but then look at
some politicians agree with them or not
like Donald Trump Michael Bloomberg
these guys have more money than God you
know Donald Trump never took a salary as
the President of the United States it
was like it's like four hundred thousand
dollars it's a chump change he didn't
need it anyway so he you know left it
and left it to the government to do
something better with supposedly these
guys really don't have they are addicted
yes probably they love power and they
love the game but they really didn't
come into you know Michael Bloomberg
joint becoming the mayor of New York and
eventually running for president and
Donald Trump running for president they
didn't get into it for the money you
know and the opportunity to to make well
they're not bought and controlled by the
system right and that's why they are all
actually that's why Bloomberg's
presidential run went nowhere no knowing
they were not supporting him because he
was just another Trump even though he
was a Milder version of him more liberal
and that's why it makes perfect sense
why Biden's in there because the people
who really control [ __ ] they want
someone that they could they want a
puppet they don't want someone that's
hard to manage wife of Representative
Alan Leventhal Democrat California so
Boeing [ __ ] oh my God no way just a day
before a committee her husband sound
released a bombshell report that alleged
Boeing Leadership was partly to blame
for two seven three seven matches holy
[ __ ] that is [ __ ] that is crazy
and you thought I sold those Bunning
shares because I had information that
there was about to be a damning report
revealing their culpability in some air
crashes I sold those shares to find a
surprise birthday party and you've just
spoiled it you're just like your father
although what I will say about your
father is he's very reliable when he
sits on committees and he wouldn't be
influenced by knowing that we have
shares in Boeing phew the most active
Traders were also those who may have had
them
the most active Traders were those who
may have had the most Insider
information
44 of the 50 most active traders in
Congress had conflicts of interest so
the ones who were doing it most are the
ones that are most culpable most likely
to be guilty these are the people making
the rules that is so funny I didn't even
know what to say about it I've known
about it hearing these details like
certain details that I didn't know about
before it just really upsets me it just
really makes me feel like such a puppet
and so you know I have moments of
feeling just completely perilous against
this machine but I know that we're not
you know I mean I shake that off pretty
quickly but it is pretty discouraging in
humanity it's nuts it's not someone in
Congress even though I don't know
nothing about it because I would never
get involved I just love stocks and
shares man I trade stocks and shares for
the love of it I love my stock trading
down the streets man I'm just doing like
getting entertaining again
planes keep crashing and it's their
fault sell
the analysis doesn't even capture all
problematic trades for instance Speaker
of the House Nancy Pelosi's husband is
famous for purchasing shares of
companies like Amazon and meta which
Pelosi is responsible for regularly
doesn't sit on a committee she was not
included in the study how convenient
it's so convenient how convenient this
is the same lady con people monsters and
telling you to put your mask on the same
lady what do you even say to this she is
she is actually just a horrible person
despite ongoing concerns about lawmakers
Financial transactions there is minimal
regulation on stock trade because like
it's not a bug it's a feature it's not a
bug it's a feature you can't do that
otherwise there's no point in the whole
system hey guys we can't trade stocks
and shares anymore see you then bye see
you everyone just go there's no point
doing it that's the reason hey guys wow
that's crazy that's like a crazy thing
to think about the only reason they're
really doing it is like that's their way
that's how they know how to make money
like oh I get all this information might
as well do the job and then just make
tens of Millions on the side yeah but if
you can't do that well I'll just find
another way to make money it's like what
are other people's jobs perks include
you know like maybe if you have a really
good uh you win the highest sales for
the quarter you get like a three-day
cruise or something or something or you
get you know extra vacation day they get
to make every Rule and make tens of
millions of dollars yeah off of you they
get to make when you're buying stocks
and they're selling it someone's losing
and every in every trade someone's
taking like taking a loss so if they're
making tens of millions of dollars it's
off of people you know what I mean
that's how it works this is imagine
having that much power and still being
attracted and then walking around and
saying that's what happened they're more
morally Superior to us they are people
would get involved in politics that
genuinely cared about ordinary people
people that had no other motivation
you're a human I'm a human you know how
difficult it is not to be like oh God my
kids in this football team I want them
to win oh oh [ __ ] I'd make a few bucks
here if I was like we're human beings
we're valuable the system has to change
change in order to elevate the best
aspects of us and the best among us not
to create a Cess pit with a scum of the
earth rise to the top when the people
control the money the control who even
gets into that position and then those
people are corrupt what do you what do
you do what do you what do you do you
know what I mean there's people above it
all that control those people even
getting into that position yeah so yeah
you want to say like get people who
really care in office but like the
elites wouldn't let that happen there's
a reason that these people are there
because they're bought and controlled oh
they make tens of millions that's
nothing to us it gets us what we want
you know what I mean yeah most members
of Congress are still free to make
trades that could conflict with their
legislative Duty as long as they
disclose the information within 45 days
which many do not know who regulates
that then they're regulating themselves
on following on making sure that they're
following that rule he's probably just
gonna say that right now okay well
listen it is difficult I understand it I
love trading myself so if you are going
to trade will you at least tell us
within 45 days that you did trade no the
2012
report despite renewed chatter about the
importance of cracking down on they just
tell their family members too what
happens you know what I mean yeah like
all right it's like it's what Jordan
Belfort did he didn't have all his money
under his name he gave it to a bunch of
different People Pumped the stocks to
his company had them sell they gave him
the cash and then he shipped it overseas
to those Banks so he didn't get caught
you just do the same [ __ ] he cousin a
husband buy this [ __ ] so Bowen the
planes are blowing up get out but
actually regulate yourself it's so low
it's laughable how low is it like like
that low
that's too loud it's all performative
it's not going anywhere one Senate
staffer told the New York Post
proponents of legislation that would ban
members of Congress from Trading stocks
say that Democratic Party leaders are
stalling on the bill though house
Speaker Nancy Pelosi Democrat California
claimed last week that lawmakers are
finally ready to bring a bill to ban
Congress from Trading stocks to a vote
by the end of this month proponents of
the ban are skeptical that that is the
case according to interviews with
lawmakers here's what I predict they
might they'll do a big ceremony about it
Joe Biden or sign tank with a pen
probably quivering and shaking as he
goes then a couple of months or a year
later they'll repeal it and no one will
hear about it because it'll be some
other thing okay
is that what they did the first time
that's what he said that's what he just
said they did the first time and frankly
they are losing on every single issue
you know uh foreign policy inflation you
know Health Care they've done nothing
you know they're the only issue that
they really have is uh if you get into
um Roe v Wade you know people or angry
about that but the people that are going
to be voting about that are there are a
lot of people that will take that into
consideration but at the end of the day
if people can't afford groceries and now
we're finding out that our heating bills
for this some this winter are going to
be up 50 percent when we have all the
gas in this country right here we have
so many we have reserves for the but the
environment but the environment can open
up restart the Keystone Keystone
Pipeline there's so much we could be
doing to alleviate American Financial
suffering right now that we're not doing
so they're trying desperately to do
something to
um I'm gonna say they're doing she's
talking about this now they're doing
this just to try to instill trust have
the public go oh but look at the
Integrity she wouldn't do that if they
wouldn't do that if they weren't
wonderful and they doing all the best
things they could for us so I predict
that that's why they're doing it just to
[ __ ] find something to try to win on
or make themselves look trustworthy but
I also have full faith faith in Russell
Brand's prediction that it will quietly
disappear if it ever gets passed at all
it's a common thing with elections where
they'll put up a simple crutch or a
quick fix to try to fix the economy like
just before the election that way
they're just more likely to win and then
from there that you know they don't give
a [ __ ] they don't care if it has a bad
like a way worse effect two down like
two years down the line if it helps them
win in the meantime oh [ __ ] let's do it
you know I want more I want to stay and
stay in office but they tried with the
inflation reduction act which fooled
literally no one into thinking that
inflation was going to be improved and
it has not so I'm lawmakers think that
the Democratic leaders could be delaying
because they're personally against the
plan representative I mean they knew
that printing trillions of dollars would
just ruin the economy like how did they
do that all over Cove like the this
pandemic how do you how did they do it's
crazy
gone
[Music]
[Music]